[Musique]
au printemps dernier montréal a reçu de
la visite inusité enrc a la bosse à
fasciner des milliers de personnes en
pleine pandémie
aujourd'hui on va tenter de comprendre
pourquoi ce géant des mers s'est
aventuré aussi loin dans le fleuve saint
laurent dans un environnement
inhospitalier qui lui aura finalement
été fatale
varennes 9 juin 2020 au loin une masse
sombre
difficilement identifiables
plus on s'en approche plus que redoutait
la population et les scientifiques se
confirme
à fleur d'eau le rorqual à bosse gît au
milieu du fleuve saint laurent à 450 km
de son aire d'alimentation
la baleine qui a émerveillé et ému les
citoyens de montréal et partout au
québec est morte
probablement déçu d'une collision avec
le navire
[Musique]
l'histoire la baleine dans le bus parle
de montréal sera-t-elle en concentré des
grands enjeux qu'on a à partager la
planète avec les baleines
malheureusement la fin est triste mais
cette histoire mais elle se répète tous
les jours cet enjeu lot de cohabitation
toutes les espèces de baleines qui
remonte le saint laurent pour venir se
nourrir on face à ce défi là de
cohabitation
mais qu'est ce qui a poussé ce jeune
rorqual à quitter la région de tadoussac
pour remonter le fleuve jusqu'à montréal
voici son histoire
[Musique]
c'est vers mai et juin dans l'estuaire
maritime du saint laurent que les
rorqual à bosse arrive des caraïbes où
ils ont passé l'hiver
ce groupe de cétacés est en pleine
expansion une fois chez nous ces
baleines s'alimente intensivement dans
le secteur de tadoussac et certaines ont
pu commencer à s'y sentir à l'étroit
imaginons que le nom de rorqual à bosse
menthe et augmente ça fait de la
pression sur les ressources à augmente
la compétition dans son habitat
traditionnel et il ya quelques jeunes
qui vont décider d'aller explorer
c'est probablement ce qu'a fait ce
rorqual à bosse la première observation
à l'extérieur de son aire d'alimentation
remonte au 24 mai la femelle d'environ
deux ans est alors à 100 kilomètres en
amont de tadoussac à sainte irénée dans
charlevoix la baleine a été vu tout près
de la rive
durant quelques heures en train de
s'alimenter de caplan très abondant
cette année c'est un jeune peu
d'expérience
il ya beaucoup de poissons il monte avec
le poisson la paix est bonne le snack
est bon est ce que je continue c'est
tout à fait possible
deux jours plus tard l'improbable se
produit rapidement ces images prises par
un pêcheur près du pont de québec ont
fait le tour du web est allé pêcher qui
à l'aller 5 n'a pas à l'heure vous
terminiez sortir un camp de ne pas donc
bondi on attendait le brésil c'est à ce
moment que robert michaud et l'équipe du
réseau québécois d'urgences pour les
mammifères marins entre en scène qu'on
appelle nos collègues
préparez-vous on ne sait pas ce que la
baleine va retourner ce soir dans le
parc marin c'est quoi la suite
hélas les heures ont passé on une autre
observation à portneuf le lendemain kg
bien nous on commence à voir
l'inévitable bon mais cet animal est en
route vers montréal
alors on a mis en marche une opération
de suivi à ce moment là
cette cavale est exceptionnel selon les
experts c'est la première fois que
rorqual à bosse avance aussi loin dans
la portion fluvial du saint laurent
il ne semble pas vouloir s'arrêter on a
envoyé une équipe du réseau québécois
d'urgences pour les mammifères marins
avec nos équipements d'observation
attraper la balle un peu plus loin dans
son périple on est arrivé en même temps
qu'elle dans le vieux port de montréal
[Applaudissements]
voici les premières images de la baleine
le 30 mai à montréal
au début il ya du découragement parce
que c'est pas un bon endroit pour un
parc à la base se retrouver fait face à
plusieurs défis
notre première inquiétude c'est les
collisions le harcèlement est ce que et
beaucoup de gens qui vont vouloir aller
sur l'eau voir la valeur très rapidement
de nombreux curieux se massent le long
des rives du saint laurent
et si plutôt sympa la baleine de
montréal quoi c'est rare donc on en
profite
au grand étonnement des scientifiques et
des montréalais
la baleine se donne en spectacle et quel
spectacle
à ce moment la baleine a l'air en bonne
santé
son état ne semble pas se dégrader même
si elle n'est pas en eau salée et qu'il
pourrait avoir de la difficulté à
trouver de la nourriture
mais le mammifère marin ne pourra pas
tenir plusieurs semaines dans ces
conditions que les grandes questions
surviennent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est quoi les scénarios
qu'est ce qui peut arriver à cet animal
l'idée de sortir de l'eau un animal de
10 mètres qui pèse 17 tonnes et de le
transporter vers tadoussac est
impensable
alors peut-on intervenir pour lui faire
rebrousser chemin sur 450 km
ailleurs sur la planète des balles elles
se sont aussi retrouvés dans deux
fâcheuse position
après avoir commis des erreurs de
parcours
pour prendre la meilleure décision
robert michaud et son équipe se sont
tournés vers la médecin vétérinaire
américaine frances gordon une sommité
mondiale en matière d'intervention
auprès des mammifères marins
en 2008 françois hollande a tenté de
faire faire demi-tour à 2 hors cac la
bosse qui s'était aventuré à quelque 110
km de l'océan pacifique dans la rivière
sacramento mais sans succès nous avons
fait jouer des sons de baleines à bosse
en aval pour les attirer ou des sondés
polar pour les faire fuir
on a aussi passé des remorqueurs à
proximité et toutes ces activités n'ont
duré qu'un impact sur les baleines après
trois semaines dans la rivière
les deux baleines sont finalement
repartis d'elle-même vers le golden gate
et le pacifique
alors j'ai dit à robert michaud que le
plus important c'est de réduire les
dérangements
je lui ai suggéré que son équipe s est
principalement de protéger la baleine ce
trafic maritime et de lui donner le
temps de retourner par elle même en aval
du fleuve
les recommandations de francisco l'inde
dont celle de ne pas intervenir ont
trouvé écho à montréal alors nous on a
décidé dans ce col en particulier de
laisser-aller la nature durant le jour
les autorités ont patrouillé sur le
fleuve pour s'assurer qu'aucune
embarcation ne s'approche à moins de 100
mètres du rorqual à bosse on a aussi
demandé à la marine marchande de
ralentir la vitesse des navires et
d'être vigilants par endroits le fleuve
n'est pas large et pas toujours très
profond ce qui rend encore plus probable
les risques de collision à ce moment
robert michaud est encore optimiste
l'expérience d'autres hors cac la bosse
qui ont fait des derricks semblables
nous enseigne que ces animaux lol plus
souvent retourne deux mènent à l'eau
salée à un endroit plus propice et l'on
compte les dodos en continu de nous
parce que plus le retour se fera tôt -
les conséquences pour l'animal seront
importants les jours passent et la
baleine continue de nager en face de
montréal puis le 7 juin on la perd de
vue
deux jours plus tard le 9 juin au matin
la baleine est retrouvée morte au milieu
du fleuve à une trentaine de kilomètres
en aval du vieux port de montréal
[Musique]
s'amorce alors un difficile travail de
récupération
il faut remorquer les normes carcasse en
décomposition est rempli de gaz la
baleine est finalement sorti de l'eau à
sorel devant une foule de curieux et
sous l'oeil des caméras
le lendemain l'équipe de la faculté de
médecine vétérinaire de l'université de
montréal débute la nécropsies
durant de longues heures les
scientifiques observent autant
l'extérieur que l'intérieur de l'animal
on veut déterminer son sexe l'état de sa
chair son alimentation récente et la
présence de parasites et puis une
première piste sérieuse émergent
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'animal
présentait quand même des signes de
traumatisme possible c'est vrai car
présence des matons d'hémorragie qui
suggèrent fortement que l'animal a été
frappé par un bateau
cette conclusion est plausible puisque
l'étude du comportement de cette jeune
baleine avant sa mort laisse croire
qu'elle n'était pas atteinte d'une
maladie
pour en avoir le coeur net des tissus
ont été prélevés et envoyés en
laboratoire pour analyse
durant le séjour de la baleine à
montréal la pression populaire et
médiatique pour la sauver a été intense
et ce afin trajet en a déçu plusieurs or
et ont pu faire mieux
si on fait notre post mortem on regarde
l'ensemble de l'opération
une question qui demeure picon devront
résoudre c'est est ce qu'on aurait dû
suivre l'animal 24 sur 24
est-ce qu'on aurait dû le faire c'est
une question qui vaut rester ouverte
est ce que ça aurait changé l'issue est
ce que on aurait pu en voyant le navire
en voyant la baleine dans la proximité
est ce qu'on aurait pu changer la course
possiblement pas
[Musique]
que votre s'il restait du passage de ce
visiteur exceptionnelle qui a apporté un
vent de fraîcheur aux montréalais au
moment où la planète vivait une crise
sanitaire sans précédent
un géant qui lui nous voir à montréal
espérons que l'histoire de cette baleine
doivent rester un script dans le coeur
et dans la tête des gens seulement dans
lequel se passe ici dans la tête et le
coeur des gens parce que nous on
applique à 450 kilomètres en aval de
montréal vivre des animaux magiques qui
ont des enjeux de cohabitation comme
celle-là en a eu dans le vieux port de
montréal et qu'on peut trouver des
solutions
[Musique]